well I was interested in science
actually and decided to go into medicine
as an area of science that could do some
good and I started out in the area of
internal medicine seeing patients
something I liked got involved in
setting up and working in some of the
First Community Health type projects and
enjoyed that but wanted to expand into
public health and after I did my
residency I went to the Centers for
Disease Control and did infectious
disease work and after that went to
Massachusetts worked in the State Health
Department to understand how things work
at the state and there I was going to
settle down and isn't teaching and and
work in the state but President Carter
and and the task force for child
survival asked me if I would go to
Uganda to help president Museveni who
had just taken over to try to rebuild
the health system of Uganda which was an
absolute tattered mess after 15 years of
kind of craziness and it was an amazing
opportunity to go do it I took a look at
it I did not go to do aids but when I
was there of course I started asking
questions like what's the male-female
ratio of you know cases so far what's
the age distribution simple things and
people have looked at that so I began to
look at it and then we set up the first
surveillance system for AIDS and my
moment you know my epiphany came when we
did a thorough survey of a survey of the
population random and took blood and
looked to see whether people HIV
positive and the numbers came back and I
said to my girlfriend who's doing the
analysis I said this can't be right i
mean you've made a decimal place era and
she said i think it's right and by the
lab people said lab test doesn't work
and of course it did and that was really
what defined to me the magnitude of the
problem or at least that you know the
iceberg part of the problem the big you
know part under the water and and so at
the end of that I I left came back and
ran the health programs of the
Rockefeller Foundation and they're a
group of people came to me since this
was my area of research and said the
AIDS vaccine effort is dead
how I got involved in in looking at and
I'm starting around at that moment in
time people perceive the AIDS epidemic
is being bad very bad and and it's
interesting because even now the
statistics you know are much worse than
they were perceived even at that moment
but you know the question was you know
why was there not a vaccine and when
people first figured out that this was a
virus people said we need a vaccine
that's how we deal with viral illnesses
and so it would have been the natural
thing to do in fact there are
predictions that have a vaccine within a
couple of years initially it was turned
out to be very difficult science
challenge and on top of that there was a
lot of pressure to try to develop drugs
for this virus um at that moment in time
we didn't know how to make drugs for
viruses but the activists in a sense
they deserve the Nobel Prize they pushed
and said you know you've got to make
money available you got to drive science
and so that's what they did so there was
this intense push to get drugs which is
by the way why we have more drugs for
HIV than all other viruses put together
now but the vaccine effort really
dropped down and and it was not a lot of
money that was not a lot of attention
not a lot of activist and not a lot of
focus on the needs of the developing
world and so the question was could we
do something about that and that was
really the origin of the International
AIDS vaccine initiative question was
should it be you know a consortium of
companies should it be a for-profit
not-for-profit and since there had never
been this type of product development
initiative we ended up having a lot of
consultation and decided to create a
not-for-profit product development
public-private partnership and the
mission of the organization is to try to
you know accelerate the development of
an AIDS vaccine for use throughout the
world and the critical part of the
mission statement is to ensure it no
it's we don't have to be the ones to
develop it we just want to make sure
member